this is a different sort of assembly
for these school girls to attend in the
nigerian state
of zamfara instead of a classroom
they sat in a government building with a
little food to eat
after a terrifying ordeal at the hands
of kidnappers
279 were captured at their school
in a town called jigabe then forced to
march
into the forest
most of us got injured on our feet and
we could not continue with the trekking
they said they will shoot anybody who
did not continue to walk
while we were walking they were hitting
us with guns and beating us with a cane
and telling us to move on
the students spent three days in the
forest but the police pronounced them
fine and well i guess you can assess the
condition themselves they are healthy
and happy
mass abductions have become increasingly
common
in northern nigeria as criminal gangs
and bandits seek payment for the
children's return
for the pupils and the parents it can be
traumatic
i'm happy i'm happy
hi like like just i was born just now
now and i feel
very vain like i
care we thank almighty the nigerian
president
said he was overjoyed at their return
and criticized local officials
for paying ransoms with cash and cars
security analysts warn this criminal
activity
won't go away for us to hear that all of
them have been
released you know you know we
were happy about that you know but then
you
now say to yourself where next because
you're wondering
where is it going to happen again is it
still going to be in zamfara
is it going to nigeria is it moving to
katsina
that's a big issue the girls were taken
by a gang of men 100 strong in military
style uniforms
although 50 or so managed to escape by
hiding under beds
or in toilet cubicles local officials
said
they negotiated the girl's release but
many will ask if money was involved
it's a common practice and it may be
necessary
but it fuels these terrifying crimes
john sparks sky news